[Music]
Beyonce all smiles on date night with
hubby Jay-Z
[Music]
check out the couple walking hand in
hand leaving Italian Hot Spot Giorgio
Baldi in Santa Monica so much fun the
pair was in good spirits following their
romantic dinner I'm just blessed and
seems only right after the singer scored
nine Grammy knobs for her latest album
Renaissance
[Music]
pretty amazing and get this the married
couple is breaking records too J and B
are tied at 88 Grammy nods each the most
nominated artists in the history of the
award show this makes me proud I just
feel so powerful and I feel I feel
fortunate that God has given me this
gift she's uh super
um detail-oriented obviously as you can
see from my work and she's uh incredibly
hard worker super talented
very inspiring Beyonce's Renaissance was
a long time coming her first studio
album since lemonade in 2016.
and head of renaissance's release B's
Mama Tina Knowles Lawson was all sorts
of proud she put two years of love into
this
many many nights all night working and
so I can't wait for the for the world to
hear it
[Music]
it feels good to know that the hard work
paid off but even with a seriously busy
career B always makes family a priority
uh-huh
you figured that last month at Tina's
wearable art Gala B J made it a night to
remember alongside their eldest daughter
10 year old Blue Ivy we've been dreaming
about this for a year and planning it
and just to see it come to fruition
everybody looks so beautiful everybody
was so all the performers were so
gracious to fly here from across the
world to be here tonight and we just
feel very supported and blue even got in
on the silent auction and bit some big
bucks
hahaha
I see in Blue Ivy do that it's just one
of those moments she was like wow she's
bidding on things I can't afford Blue
Ivy sitting there with the paddle and I
was like I know you're gonna be a kid I
know this kid kid is going to come at me
tonight she's 11. yes looking like she's
21 man I'm like this girl's growing up
so quickly and said we're getting old
but hey we like to think getting old
means getting better and with Beyonce's
beautiful family and nine Grammy Noms
life sure does seem sweets
[Music]